here we are in what has now been
transformed into the lunchroom which
some would argue is the most important
event of the day so the sessions have
now been put on hold
giving everyone a chance to eat and
drink
I'm sure the wine tastes lovely so
whilst they're enjoying their fine
dining experience it's time for us to
understand a little bit more about the
scale of this event in numbers
now we're very lucky to be joined here
by the wonderfully talented and
extremely busy Nadya now Nadya
what's your feelings now for the first
day of the ftth conference I'm very
excited and very busy as you said as you
can see the event already is very full
and it has gathered more than three
thousand participants so this is again
the largest ftth focused event in the
world which is really great and just to
tell you the number of journalists that
we had we had 140 already in this venue
140 journalists and analysts are
gathered here from 15 countries so this
is there really an amazing event so far
I'm very glad about this
we're now joined by Mark Henry without
whom I'm sure none of this event would
even be happening so Mark Henry but I'm
a comer again taking care of the
logistics here at the ftth conference
now can you give us maybe some key facts
and figures so that we can understand a
little bit more about this addition here
in London yes of course
as opposed to what people may think this
is not a niche event anymore
ten years ago we were welcoming 150
guests we now speak about more than
3-thousand delegates more than 20,000
square meters of Expo and meeting rooms
more than 160 speakers we have more than
100 waiters more than 3500 statistics
cetera so this is a big event and we
don't speak just about the quantities
but also about the qualities the level
of the of the delegates is extremely
high and we we take great care of them
and this is certainly one of the success
of this event this is the quality of the
place and the people you can meet and
network with so that we have it quite a
lot of impressive numbers I just wanted
to add something among all those very
impressive figures I just wanted to say
that with just one but a wonderful FTTH
TV presenter you're too kind Marc Andre
really I'm flattered
you